>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Rob Casper: I remember the
first time I encountered a poem
by Marilyn Hacker in the 1992
volume of "Best American Poetry".
I was a college junior, newly in
love with poetry and eager to take
in all its contemporary versions.
And, the annual series
seemed a good place to start.
I was introduced to much
in that year's volume,
guest edited by Charles Simic,
including many free-wheeling,
free-versed poems by
friends, teachers,
and even a few poets laurate I
would meet in the decades to come.
But, the only poem I remember
encountering still was
"Elysian Fields".
In a rhyming iambic pentameter
that is as strict talking
as it is subtly artful, the poem
portrays any given gentrifying block
in New York City.
It functions as a kind
of survey of the stories
and conflicts worth
capturing in a timeless form.
Looking at "Elysian Fields" now, as
someone who has lived in Brooklyn
for the last 16 years, I'm
reminded of how this poem
and this poet continue to
challenge me to be open to the world
and its difficult and
implicating truths.
I was happy to see "Elysian Fields"
in Marilyn Hacker's newest book,
"A Stranger's Mirror: New and
Selected Poems, 1994-2014",
published last year by
W.W. Norton & Company.
And, I'm delighted to have Marilyn
here today to honor her more
than 40 years of publishing as well
as the work she's done
in the last two decades.
I'm sure there are
many, many poetry lovers
with touchtone Marilyn
Hacker poems of their own,
and in the next half hour, I
wouldn't be surprised if she, again,
changed my sense of the art.
Please join me in welcoming
Marilyn Hacker.
[ Applause ]
>> Marilyn Hacker: Thank you so
much, and it's a great pleasure
to be here and with all of you and
to listen to and to follow some
of the other writer, marvelous
writers in this festival.
I was at A.B. Spellman's
and Joy Harjo's reading
earlier this morning, and,
and they were wonderful and
this is a wonderful occasion,
and I'm going to make sure one
of these water bottles is open.
It is also f-ing cold in here.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I coincidence, I had planned
to, I made up the little list
and the poem that you just
mentioned was on the list.
So, why don't I start there?
[ Background Conversation ]
Elysian Fields, and this is a poem
about the Upper West
Side of Manhattan.
"Champs Elysees of Broadway" says
the awning of the café where,
every Sunday morning young
lawyers in old jeans ripped
at the knees do crosswords.
Polyglot Lebanese run it: they've
taken on two more shopfronts
and runner, run their banner
down all three at once.
Four years ago, their sign "Au
Petit Beurre" was so discrete
that meeting someone there, I'd tell
her the street corner, not the name.
They were in the right
place at the right time.
Meanwhile, the poor
are trying hard enough.
Outside, on Broadway, people sell
their stuff laid out on blankets,
cardboard cartons, towels.
A stout matron with lacquered auburn
curls circles the viridian throw rug
and painted plaster San
Martin to hug a thinner,
darker woman who hugs her volubly
back in Spanish, a neighbor,
I guess, and guess
they still have houses.
The man with uncut,
browned, French paperbacks,
he mans with two embroidered
gypsy blouses
and three pilled pitiful pairs
of plaid slacks folded behind him
on the pavement where there was a
Puerto Rican hardware store that's
been a vacant shopfront
for three years may not.
There's a young couple down
the block from our corner.
She's tall, gaunt, gangly,
black; he's short, quick,
voluble, unshaven, white.
They sit up dry mornings
around eight.
I've seen him slap her
face, jerking her thin arm
like a rag doll's - a
dollar kept from him.
She moves too slow,
whore, stupid bitch...
"She's my wife," he tells a
passing man who stops and watches.
If anyone did call the cops,
it would be to prevent them
and their stacks of old Vogues
and outdated science texts
from blocking access
to the "upscale bar"
where college boys
get bellicose on beer.
"Leave him" would I say?
Does she have keys to
an apartment, to a room,
a door to close behind her?
What we meant by "poor"
when I was 20 was a tenement
with clanking pipes and roaches,
what we meant was up six flights
of grimed piss-pungent
stairs, four babies
and a baby-faced welfare worker
forbidden to say "birth control".
I was almost her, on the New
York State Employment Services,
at the East 14th Street
Branch, whose job it was
to send day workers, mostly black,
to clean other people's houses.
Five-fifteen, and I
walked east, south,
walked up my own four flights.
Poor was a neighbor, was next
door, is still a door away.
The door is mine.
Outside, the poor work
Broadway in the rain.
The cappuccino drinkers
watch them pass
under the awning from
behind the glass.
And, as Audre Lorde used to say,
"Save the energy for the end."
[ Laughter ]
This, much more recently, was
written, in part in memory
of the great American poet Adrienne
Rich, who died a few years ago,
and written during, what is going
on now in, in Iraq, in Syria,
in Palestine, in so many places.
Were the mountain women
sold as slaves
in the city my friend has not
written from for two weeks?
One of the just has
given back his medal.
I wake up four times in the
night soaked with sweat.
In the city my friend
has not written from,
for two weeks there was
almost enough electricity.
I wake up four times in
the night soaked with sweat
and change my shirt
and go to sleep again.
There was almost enough electricity
to heat water, make tea, bathe,
write e-mails and change her
shirt and go to sleep again.
Her mother has gallstones.
Her sister mourns.
Heat water, make tea, bathe,
write e-mails to Mosul,
New York, London, Beirut.
Her sister mourns a teenaged son who
died in a stupid household accident.
To Mosul, Havana, London, Beirut,
I change the greeting,
change the alphabet.
War like a stupid household
accident changes the optics
of a scene forever.
I change the greeting,
change the alphabet: Hola,
morning of light, ya compañera.
Change the optics of a
scene forever present,
and always altogether elsewhere.
Morning of roses, kiss you,
hasta luego to all our
adolescent revolutions, present
and always altogether elsewhere.
It seemed as if something
would change for good tomorrow.
All our adolescent
revolutions gone gray,
drink exiles' coffee,
if they're lucky.
It seemed as if something
would change for good tomorrow.
She was our conscience
and she died too early.
The gray exiles drink
coffee, if they're lucky.
Gaza's survivors sift
through weeping rubble.
She was our conscience, but she
died too early, after she spoke
of more than one disaster.
Cursing, weeping, survivors
sift through rubble.
One of the just has given
back his medal after he spoke
of more than one disaster.
How can we sing our
songs if we are slaves?
And, this is a more
private, not private.
It's not private at all, but a poem
about something closer to home.
It's about friendship, and
it's called "An Absent Friend".
Perched on a high stool, the
auburn sybil eats Fig Newtons,
elbows on the sink, the
other lively hand exhorting.
Think through these
words to silences.
Think to refill the teapot.
The waters come to a boil.
It's four A.M. Tea steeps.
We pour, we drink it milky, volley,
talk, talk, link lines read out loud
from some book on the pile
accumulated on the scarred oak table
to some felicity of memory.
The black cat hums like a fridge.
The three daughters are
asleep in different rooms.
Through the steamed window
on the garden comes pearl
dawnlight, lovely and unremarkable.
Lovely and unremarkable the
clutter of mugs and books,
the almost empty Fig Newtons box,
thick dishes in a big tin tray,
the knife still standing in the
butter, change like the color
of river water in the
delicate shift to day.
Thin fog veils the hedges where
a neighbor dog makes rounds.
"Go to bed.
It doesn't matter about
the washing-up.
Take this book along."
Whatever it was we said
that night is gone,
framed like a photograph
nobody took.
Stretched out on a
camp cot with the book,
I think that we will talk
all night again there,
or another where, but I am wrong.
This was written a couple of years
ago at an international festival
in Konya in Turkey which was the
place where Rumi all his life
and wrote everything that he wrote,
and where, in fact, he's buried.
And, the, at the, at the conference,
there were people from Turkey,
from the United States, from
Iran, for Pakistan, from Syria.
And, from Germany.
And, I wrote some poems, and this
one is in the, in the Hazal form
which we get from Urdu and from
Farsi and which was popularized or,
if that's the right word, in English
by the wonderful Kashmiri
American Poet Agha Shahid Ali
who also died much,
much, much too soon.
And, in the Hazal, the poet, there,
it's a series of, of connect,
of couplets that are often
completely unconnected except
by a rhyme and a repeated word and
you're supposed to put your name
or perhaps some version of it in
the last, in the very last couplet.
And, this is dedicated to a young
woman from Afghanistan [inaudible]
who was at that conference
and to [inaudible] a Pakistani
novelist who's an old friend
who was there, too.
Outside the door -- and
one, oh one more thing.
[inaudible] who was maybe 25
years old was talking about how
in Afghanistan, when she was a
child, her father and her uncle
and their friends would get together
and recite Hazals all night long,
out loud, drinking tea and, drinking
tea, smoking, and reciting poems.
And she, as a child and as a girl
child, wasn't allowed to come in,
but she would sit outside the
door and listen to everything
that they were, the poems they
were reciting out loud and try
to memorize as much as she could.
So, that was the start of this.
Laughter, music, voices singing
verses can be heard outside
the door.
The little girl is memorizing
every word outside the door.
Light in the stairwell,
seen through the judas-hole:
is that the visitor you longed for
or you feared outside the door?
Long hours in lamplight practicing
his scales, in counterpoint
to solfège of a bird
outside the door.
The diplomat entering the
leader's office forgets the Copt,
the communist, the
Kurd outside the door.
Praise for the leader,
loyalty till death!
Another imprecation is
whispered outside the door.
The first love left, the
second packs her bags.
Are those the nervous footsteps
of the third outside the door?
Self is a mirror, poster-color
bright,
but notice how the colors
become blurred outside the door.
The revolutionaries'
nameless laundress wonders
"What happens to a dream deferred?"
outside the door.
At this next poem, much
New York in it, too,
is an elegy for my good
friend who died much too soon,
the wonderful poet and writer
and teacher June Jordan.
And, it's called "Elegy for
a Soldier", and those of you
who know June's work, know
that she wrote an auto --
a memoir, an autobiography called,
"Soldier" because that was what
her dad who was a very strict man
from Jamaica who really wanted
her to succeed in the world.
He called her Little Soldier.
One. The city where
I knew you was swift.
A lover cabbed to Brooklyn (broke,
but so what) after the night shift
in a Second Avenue diner.
The lover was a Quaker, a
poet, an anti-war activist.
Was blonde, as twenty-four.
Wet snow fell on the access
road to the Manhattan Bridge.
I was neither lover, slept uptown.
But the arteries, streetlights,
headlines, phonelines,
feminine plural links ran silver
through the night city as dawn
and the yellow cab passed
on the frost-blurred bridge,
headed for that day's
last or first coffee.
The city where I knew you was
rich in bookshops, potlucks,
ad hoc debates, demos,
parades and picnics.
There were walks I liked to take.
I was on good terms with two rivers.
You turned, burned, flame-wheel
of words lighting the page,
good neighbor on your homely street
in Park Slope, whose Russian zaydes,
Jamaican grocers, dyke
vegetarians, young gifted everyone,
claimed some changes -at
least a new food co-op.
In the laundromat, ordinary
women talked revolution.
We knew we wouldn't live forever
but it seemed as if we could.
The city where I knew
you was yours and mine
by birthright: Harlem, the Bronx.
Separately we left it
and came separately back.
There's no afterlife for dialogue,
divergences we never teased
apart to weave back together.
Death slams down in the midst of
all your unfinished conversations.
Whom do I address when I
address you, larger than life
as you always were, not alive now?
Words are not you,
poems are not you,
ashes on the Pacific
tide, you least of all.
I talk to my- self to
keep the line open.
The city where I knew you is gone.
Pink icing roses spelled out PASSION
on a book-shaped chocolate cake.
The bookshop's a sushi bar now,
and PASSION is long out of print.
Would you know the changed street
that cab swerved down toward you
through cold, white mist?
We have a Republican mayor.
Threats keep citizens in line:
anthrax; suicide attacks.
A scar festers where towers once
were; dissent festers unexpressed.
You are dead of a woman's disease.
Who gets to choose what
battle takes her down?
Down to the ocean, friends mourn
you, with no time to mourn.
And the second part.
You, who stood alone in the tall
bay window of a Brooklyn brownstone,
conjuring morning with
free-flying words, knew the power,
terror in words, in
flying; knew the high
of solitude while the early light
prowled Seventh Avenue, lupine,
hungry like you, your
spoils raisins and almonds,
ballpoint pen, yellow foolscap.
You, who stood alone in
your courage, never hesitant
to underline the connections
(between rape,
exclusion and occupation...)
and separations were
alone and were not alone
when morning blotted the
last spark of you out,
around you voices you
no longer had voice
to answer, eyes you were blind to.
All your loves were
singular: you scorned labels.
Claimed black; woman, and
for the rest eluded limits,
quicksilver (Caribbean),
staked out self-definition.
You, at once an optimist, a
Cassandra, Lilith in the wilderness
of her lyric, were a black American,
born in Harlem, citizen soldier.
If you had to die-and I don't admit
it- who dared, what time, "What if,
each time they kill a
black man / we kill a cop?"
couldn't you take down with
you a few prime villains
in the capitol, who are also mortal?
June, you should be living,
the states are bleeding.
Leaden words like "Homeland"
translate abandoned
dissident discourse.
Twenty years ago, you denounced the
war crimes still in progress now,
as Jenin, Rammallah dominate,
then disappear from the headlines.
Palestine: your war.
"To each nation, its
Jews," wrote Primo Levi.
"Palestinians are Jews to Israelis."
Afterwards, he died in despair,
or so we infer, despairing.
Top each nation its Jews,
its blacks, its Arabs,
Palestinians, immigrants, its women.
From each nation, its poets: Mahmoud
Darwish, Kavanaugh, Shahid (who,
beloved witness for
silenced Kashmir, cautioned,
shift the accent, and he was
"martyr"), Audre Lorde, Neruda,
Amichai, Senghor, and
you, June Jordan.
How am I doing?
And, thank you, signers.
You are amazing.
[ Applause ]
And, well, since that
poem ended with Palestine,
these are two monologues in the
voices which I, I don't know if,
sort of, daring to take
on the voices of people
who were actually alive
and had their own voices.
Of, two poets, two women, one who
was Palestinian, Fadwa Tuquan,
and one who was Israeli, Dahlia
Ravikovitch who were friends
and allies and often argued.
And, so one of these, the
first poem is in Fadwa,
is in Fadwa Tuquan's voice,
and the second in something
like Dahlia Ravikovitch's voice.
And, the poem, the first one called
"The Education of the Poet" talks
about something that
happened to Fadwa Tuquan
when she was a child
and taken out of school.
And, because of ridiculous
incident, and the second one is more
about the relationship
between the two.
So, "Fadwa: The Education
of the Poet".
When I was made a prisoner
in my father's house,
my mother turned away,
swallowing her words.
The potholed path to school
became a vision of my lost future.
It was not even because
of a letter- a boy
from the boys' school entrusted
a flower, an almond sprig,
for me, to my little brother.
That was intercepted
by our middle brother.
I was twelve.
I was no longer to leave the house.
If that twig in blossom
sullied an imagined flower,
the metaphor wasn't mine.
I had no words for my
ignorance, or innocence.
I copied letter after wobbly
letter on my school slate.
My vision was astigmatic, strained.
Was their double vision god's eyes?
Six months later, my eldest
brother came back, his studies done.
Doctor of Letters.
He shelved his books in
the attic room of the house
that became a hive, crawling
and buzzing with words
and dripping the honey of
words on a carpet of flowers.
My days were dust and water, starch
and flour, chores, silence, shame.
I could not envision the schoolchild
I'd been, or what I would be.
Words receded, I spoke so little.
I brought my brother his
coffee and shaving water.
The rest of the house
was dawn-silent.
He was writing a letter - no,
something else, carefully,
hearing each letter that rounded
or plunged like the bud or the root
of a flower, and the vowels'
perfume pervaded the house
as he weighted the choices
that shaped his revision.
"Do you still care about poetry?"
asked my brother, and
began to recite,
a mellifluous ladder of words.
"Take this book.
Copy this poem.
Make a list of the
words you don't know.
Mark the small vowel
for each letter.
Learn it, and recite it
to me," said my brother.
"We are dust and ash, and
beauty is brief as a flower.
But a stanza's a room; a single line
is the house you - you - can build,
throw open the doors
to your vision."
I live in my own house now.
In my line of vision,
an almond tree flowers.
I live by words, and on each page
I write a letter to my brothers.
And "Dahlia and Fadwa",
different voice.
When I see her come through
the orchard toward my house,
I begin composing answers
to the words
with which she'll challenge me,
her vision precise and focused,
as if every letter
were drawn beforehand.
She stops, stoops toward
a flower she doesn't pick,
and the word I'm left is "sister".
As if she were coming to visit a
younger sister after a long absence,
as if this stranger's house were
where she'd watched my awkward
gestures flower to eloquence,
as if I had measured her words
from a wider world each
time a letter arrived,
message inhabited by a vision.
But I was the only
messenger of my vision.
My father died.
There was no brother or
sister but the orphan's clan
of branching letters
I taught myself.
I moved from house to house with
a dented trunk, a few books,
many words, an acid fruit
proceeding its own flower.
Am I named for a traitor
or for a flower?
Blood and fire have cindered
and stained my vision;
I curse their politics;
they praise my words.
What answer can I give my older
sister when I open the door,
welcome her into my house,
and she hands me the incriminating
letter while I imagine opening a
letter after scouring the sink,
dusting a loaf with flour,
that tells me my house
no longer is my house.
Beyond the window and my field of
vision my son is shouting something
to his sister-and it's hard, all
at once, to make out their words.
But in my yellow kitchen there
are only words I can't pronounce
correctly, in the letters
of my sister's language,
language that is sister to mine.
I watched her flame and flower as
boys threw stones- spliced shots
on television, and felt the
leaning walls of my bright house.
In that threatened house, at a loss
for words my letter would be subject
to revision, flow or gutter,
never reach my sister.
And, I think I can
read two more poems.
[inaudible] This is a,
another poem in another voice.
There is a, yet another,
another form that we get
from another language, the
Glosa which comes from Spain.
Sixteenth, 17th century in which a
poet takes four line, four lines,
a quatrain or four consecutive
lines from a poem by somebody else
and then composes a poem of
force to stanzas each one
of which ends with
one of those lines.
And, in this case, the
four lines are from a poem
by Anna Akhmatova called
"Willow", and the speaker
of the poem is someone
like Akhmatova who,
during the Stalinist realm was
forbidden to publish her work.
And, would write poems which she
would, then, recite and learn
by heart with a friend, very often a
young widow named Lydia Chukovskaya,
and then they burned
the poems in the ashtray
and just have them in their minds.
So, the four lines form
Akhmatova in a translation
by Judith Hemschemeyer are "And
I grew up in pattern tranquility
in the cool nursery
of the new century.
And the voice of man
was not dear to me,
but the voice of the
wind I could understand."
A sibilant wind presaged
a latish spring.
Bare birches leaned and
whispered over the gravel path.
Only the river ever left.
Still, someone would bring
back a new sailor middy to wear
in the photograph of the four of us.
Sit still, stop fidgeting.
-Like the still-leafless trees with
their facility for lyric prologue
and its gossipy aftermath.
I liked to make up stories.
I liked to sing: I was encouraged
to cultivate that ability.
And I grew up in patterned
tranquility.
In the single room, with
a greasy stain like a scar
from the gas-fire's fumes, when any
guest might be a threat (and any
threat was a guest-from the
past or the future) at any hour
of the night, I would
put the tea things
out though there were scrap-leaves
of tea, but no sugar, or a lump
or two of sugar but no tea.
Two matches, a hoarded
cigarette: my day's page ashed
on its bier in a bed-sitter.
No godmother had presaged
such white nights to me
in the cool nursery
of the young century.
The human voice distorted
itself in speeches,
a rhetoric that locked
locks and ticked off losses.
Our words were bare as that stand
of winter birches while poetasters
sugared the party bosses' edicts
(the only sugar they could purchase)
with servile metaphor and simile.
The effects were mortal,
however complex the causes.
When they beat their child beyond
this thin wall, his screeches,
wails and pleas were the
gibberish of history,
and the voice of man
was not dear to me.
Men and women, I mean.
Those high-pitched voices-
how I wanted them to shut up.
They sound too much like me.
Little machines for evading
choices, little animals,
selling their minds for touch.
The young widow's voice
is just hers,
as she memorizes the words we
read and burn, nights when we read
and burn with the words unsaid,
hers and mine, as we watch
and are watched, and the
river reflects what spies.
Is the winter trees' rustling
a code to the winter land?
But the voice of the
wind I could understand.
And, this last poem does a kind
of bookend to the very first one,
is dedicated to Fadwa Suleiman
who is a Syrian writer and actor
who was very active with the
Syrian, in the Syrian revolution
when it was a peaceful uprising
folk for a change in government
and didn't opening out and
democracy, free speech,
and she left her career and cut
off all of her hair and went to
and gave talks to the
young revolutionaries
in the city, in the city of Homs.
And, not too soon afterwards, it was
not safe for her to stay in Syria.
She's now a political exile
living in France and in Paris
which is where I met her.
And, this comes from a
real, again, real incident.
Fadwa and I were walking across,
walking across the Pont ser le
and down the street talking
in my terrible Arabic
and her improving French.
And, we saw a man whom I had once,
a Syrian person whom she'd seen
and I had last seen
at a political meeting
and whom she had last seen also
speaking to the crowds in Homs.
And, he, too, now in exile.
So, that's what's behind this.
Said the old woman who
barely spoke the language:
Freedom is a dream, and
we don't know whose.
Said the insurgent
who was now an exile:
When I began to write the
story I started bleeding.
Freedom is a dream, and
we don't know whose-
that man I last saw speaking
in front of the clock tower
when I began to write the story?
I started bleeding five years after
I knew I'd have no more children.
That man I last saw
speaking in front
of the clock tower turned an
anonymous corner and disappeared.
Five years after I knew I'd have
no more children my oldest son was
called up for the army, turned an
anonymous corner and disappeared.
My nephew, my best friend, my second
sister whose oldest son was called
up for the army, are looking
for work now in other countries.
Her nephew, his best friend,
his younger sister, a doctor,
an actress, an engineer,
are looking for work now
in other countries stumbling,
disillusioned, in a new language.
A doctor, an actress, an engineer
wrestle with the rudiments
of grammar disillusioned,
stumbling in a new language,
hating their luck, and
knowing they are lucky.
Wrestling with the rudiments
of grammar, the old woman,
who barely speaks the
language, hated her luck.
I know that I am lucky said the
insurgent who is now an exile.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.